the american presidential race has taken
on a new turn following comments
allegedly made by the commander-in-chief
of the u.s armed forces
president donald trump is reported to
have disparaged americans killed in
battle
in europe the atlantic magazine broke
the story
it said trump refused to visit an
american military cemetery in france
because it was
quote filled with losers trump also
allegedly referred to marines who lost
their lives as quote
suckers for getting killed
parts of the story have been
corroborated by other news outlets
including the usually pro-trump
fox news but trump himself strongly
denies he ever made the comments
no it was a fake story written by a
magazine that was uh probably not going
to be around much longer
but it was a totally fake story and that
was confirmed by many people who were
actually there
it was a terrible thing that somebody
could say the kind of things and
especially to me because i've done more
for the military
than almost anybody else but whether
true
or not the story has angered many
veterans and has taken a grip on the u s
election democratic presidential nominee
joe biden jumped on the story and had
this to say
president trump has demonstrated he has
no sense of service
no loyalty to any cause other than
himself
and if i have the honor of being the
next commander-in-chief
i will ensure that our american heroes
know i'll have their backs honor their
sacrifice
and those who've been injured will be in
military parades
let's bring in chaz henry now a long
time national security correspondent in
washington d.c and a former marine
captain
who's reported extensively on veterans
issues uh chas
thanks for being with us how credible do
you think these reports are
well so far nick as you know all of the
sourcing has been
anonymous no one has come out and said
you know i am this person i was there
and i heard this
but more and more agencies are as you
say confirming this but again with
unnamed sources so
we look at trends so for instance in the
2016 campaign
uh we saw the president uh berate john
mccain
for his experience as a prisoner of war
and by implication other people who had
uh been prisoners of war undergone
torture
uh saying that this wasn't a heroic uh
endeavor we saw him berate
the father of an army captain uh who had
died in iraq a book that came out early
this year
said that in early 2017 early in the
president's administration he was in a
meeting at the pentagon
with the nation's top military leaders
and at that time he called them a bunch
of dopes and babies
for um being engaged in what he called
the loser war in afghanistan
uh as you note fox news correspondent
jennifer griffin
who has been on the national security
beat for a long time has confirmed
she says with two uh i think these are
former trump administration officials
who were on that trip to france
verifying uh the story that the atlantic
put forward about the president's
remarks so
um we don't know from a particular
source who's come out and
said it openly but the trending would
make this potentially believable
yeah it sounds like a pretty large trend
as you describe it do you think though
given there's an election ongoing could
it have any effect
on public opinion in the final two
months of the presidential race
potentially uh people have all sorts of
uh things that they think about and
worry about and are concerned about as
they head into the
ballot box but uh we know that
uh veterans uh can look at president
trump and see some things that he's done
for them he's encouraged in science of
legislation that
uh allowed the va to better hold
accountable bad leaders within that
agency
created a hotline for veterans if they
felt their
cases weren't being handled with
sufficient speed
and he's built on programs from the
previous administration and actually
tried to take credit for the entire
programs
having to do with providing civilian
medical care to veterans nearer where
they are
so there are things that the veterans
and people with concerns about veterans
and people in the military can look to
and uh and appreciate among uh amidst
president trump but
the idea that a commander-in-chief would
speak disparagingly
is is something that would have been
difficult for anyone to believe even if
one thought that the commanders and
chief in the past were cynical
yeah they would uh they would praise uh
and speak well of military people
uh in order to ensure that they continue
to do what's necessary to secure the
national defense
let me just jump in you sort of think
yeah
you were a marine and just briefly i
understand
his alleged comments offended many
marines why is that
well the battlegrounds of bella wood uh
are are sacred to u.s marines uh
what u.s marines did there was really
put themselves on
the map in u.s defense history
instead of digging trenches as had been
done in years before and
they had been encouraged to do by some
of the european allies
marines dug shallow holes and over the
first half of june 1918
suffered 10 000 nearly 10 000 casualties
1800 of those
dead fighting in brutal hand-to-hand uh
combat with bayonets and uh so
to uh to attack seemingly a touchstone
of that
amongst marines particularly would be
really
something that would be strongly pushed
back okay well chaz henry thanks so much
for that insight
my pleasure nick thanks
you